じゃあ五十二と五十一と五十二を読みます
［外国語］って二つです
これ意味 まあこれまた簡単ですね
今日は空いてるんですね
［外国語］美しい花ですね
［外国語］ものすごい美しい色があります
［外国語］香りもある
ルチランというのはまあ気に入るという
色があって 香りがあって
かっこいい花がある あ
［外国語］ 香りがないんだと
五十一はアガンダカンだから香りがない
花は綺麗ですけど 全然香りはない
［外国語］そのように正しい言葉であっても
［外国語］行うがない人
実践しない人には［外国語］効き目がないんだと
言葉だけでは効き目がありませんと
香りがないということは
皆様にあまり日本の花は香りがないんだからね
全然ピンとこないでしょう
花には香りがあるんですよ
残念なことに 本物の花だったら
人間の欲で 強引にあれこれともうもうもう毒ばっかし色々食わしちゃって
もう作ってる花は まぁただ形だけで
花には香りがあって まあとにかくインドではこの香り
すごい喜ぶんですよ すごくお花の香りっていうのはね
気持ち悪いもので 微妙で
もう派手っていうことでもないし
なんかすごく落ち着くというね
そういうことだから まぁ
例えばジャスミンの花とか
ほんのちょっとどこかの部屋に置いておくと
もう部屋中ずっともう何日でも
微妙に香りが人の心を気持ちを落ち着いてくれるんです
だからこの場合は日本の文化ですから
まぁあの 造花で考えてください
造花もまるっきり本物と同じに見えるでしょうに
もう時々もう完璧ですよ
本物よりも生花よりも造花
造花は でもなんかすごく違うでしょうね
なんてありがたみも何もないでしょう
別に格好悪いわけでもないでしょうにね
色がないわけでもないでしょうに
例えば写真なんか撮るとか
遠いところにちょっと目線から離れたところに飾っておけばもうバレないんですよ
全然 それぐらいリアルに造花を作ってますが
なんか違うでしょ 本当の生花と比べてみると
まあそういう差で考えてください
かっこよくて綺麗な花であっても
やっぱり造花はちょっとそんな価値がないんだと
五十二は［外国語］ 美しい花で［外国語］色もあって［外国語］香りもある
［外国語］正しい言葉がそのように［外国語］行う人に実践する人には効き目があるんだと
まぁ ブッダの言葉でもいかにすごいかと
ほんのちょっと実践してみるとわかるんであって
ただ勉強だけする人々はやがて頭がおかしくなってまっちゃうんです
全然もうそのありがたみを感じないんです
なんてすごいかと ちょっとやってみなきゃ
特に学者系の方々っていうのは
やろうという気持ちはまるっきりない
もういっぱいあるのは学者ですからと
だから何をとこちらも言いたいんですけどね
だから偉そうに言うんだけど
食いためにやってるんだっていう意味でしょうに
全然意味がわかってない
学者ってのは食いためにそれ研究しているでしょうに
あんたブッダの教えを生き生きしてそれで食ってるんですかと
実践する人は食うために食うために向き合ってるんじゃないんで
だからすごいかっこいいんですよ
ごちゃごちゃ研究しなくても
ほんのちょっと一言二言葉教えてもらって
それを実践しようとする
ものすごいかっこいいんですよ
学者よりは それでもうぐっとね
きちになる だからこの前五十番にしたってもやりなさいということでしょ？そんなに難しいことじゃないですよ
人のことはどうでもいいやと
私は自分がちゃんと生きてるのか
それだけで心配やと 自分のことだけに
それで生きていれば完璧な人間になりますよ
だから実行しなきゃいけないんです
この二行でいうのは 何といいますか
花より団子というような感じで
もう見て楽しいだけではよりより団子の方が食べられますからというね
ただ感覚的に気分だけで意味がないんだと
実行ということなんですね
実行だったらほんのちょっと僅かな実行でも十分ですよ
大げさにすごいごちゃごちゃ喋るよりはね
まあそれでそれ以上は言うことはなりませんと
お釈迦様に会う機会もあったんですけど
悟らなかった人々もいるし
お釈迦様はジータナラマという最上のね
隣いた人がもう豚を殺してね
整形手術させていた人だからね
もう地獄の一端ですよ
他の人々はもう一日かけて
時々もう何ヶ月もかけてお釈迦様に会いに来るんですよ
時々一生一回しか会えないんです
一生一回会って説法を聞いて
そのまま自分の田舎へ
村へ 町 国へ帰るんですよ
でも悟るんですよ サーワッティの町に最上にお釈迦様はもう二十九年ぐらいもうもう時々時々住んでいたのに
隣の人はすごい大きい家でしたけどね
もう豚とやっていてね
飼って育てていて だから町に必要な豚肉はその人が用意する
そこで毎日豚ばっかり殺して殺して
もう毎日豚の鳴き声を聞いていて
ある日突然もう豚を殺してる鳴き声がずっと聞こえてくるんだと
朝も昼も夜も鳴き声が聞こえる
次の日も聞こえる アーナンダ尊者がお釈迦様に隣で
動物殺してるんだから
なんかすごい気持ち悪いんですよ
仏教徒にとってはもう誰にでもね
でお釈迦様は何か隣では何か結婚式でもあるみたいだと
何日もなんかすごい豚殺してるんだと
もしかすると王様の何かあるんでしょうかとかね
巨大な国民集めて晩餐会みたいなのやるか何かそんなもんでしょう
あれほど殺してるんだから
お釈迦様 いえ 違いますよと
あの人はもう頭がイカれてるんだと
だから今 豚の鳴き声で殺す時の鳴き声で鳴いてるんだと
あと二日 三日で死にますよと
死んで まあ殺生の罪だから地獄に落ちますよ
だから頭がイカれちゃって死んじゃうと
もう天国に行けないんですよ
もうすごいその妄想ですからね
ということで だからお釈迦様にあって隣にいた人がお釈迦様の聖地の隣にいたんだからといって天国に行くわけじゃないんです
やっぱり教えを実行しなくちゃいけないんですよ
実行しようとしたら ほんのちょこっと一言葉お釈迦様から聞いていただいたっても十分です
はい 話は以上です  [咳]